so we've been given new footage in the
form of a tv spot for thor love and
thunder let's break it down this first
new shot here is all four lifting up his
accented air now we've previously seen
this shot before but this is an extended
shot as it lifts it up in the air it
looks like in the background we can see
a galaxy or something from space the
tone of this sequence seems to be more
lighthearted than serious and it's
definitely a part of the sequence which
you can see in the background here the
next new shot we have is of 4 and mighty
4 where they are in space looking at the
cosmos in the background a very very
nice looking shot i imagine this
sequence might be more of a heartfelt
moment possibly an intimate moment
between them or just them to reflect on
each other and their current
relationship status whatever that is in
this point of the movie and then we have
a new dialogue sequence which i'll just
play quickly for you guys
the one thing that i have noticed is
that they have shown korg a lot in these
trailers which leads me to believe he'll
play a big role in this film which i'm
honestly really really happy about
because he's honestly one of my favorite
characters he just has a great sense of
humor and he always steals the scene
that he is in with that out of the way
that pretty much sums up all the new
footage that we have from this tv spot
so if you did enjoy this breakdown
please like and subscribe and let me
know in the comment section below if you
want to see more breakdowns like this
thanks for watching guys